I know I know I'm 16 years old from
South Africa my question is what are the
future plans for the Europa trip and
what instruments will be utilized to
drill beneath the earth's surface so the
big news here in the United States is
this mission to Europa mission is what
we call spacecraft and all the people
that work to support it the mission to
Europa is now in phase B in other words
it's after phase a so it's been funded
there's money being spent selecting
instruments for a spacecraft to go out
to Europa the moon of Jupiter with twice
as much sea water as the earth looking
for signs of life is a tricky business
because the spacecraft to be going very
very fast in order to get out there and
get an orbit around Europa without just
smashing into it so when you said the
Earth's surface I bet you meant the
Europan Ian surface you'd the Europa and
surface so along this line I'm reluctant
to call him our hero but there's a
congressman in the US Senate in the US
Congress named John Culberson and he is
a huge fan of sending a mission to
Europa he has a daughter who's 19 I
believe and he wants it so that she will
know whether or not there were life on
it there's life on Europa just like you
and so he he has put in the
congressional bill this is here in the
United States this is the laws and
regulations that provide money to NASA
the world's largest Space Agency he has
put money in there to land and make a
lander for Europa and in general the
lander would be a thing with insect
looking legs and then some drill that
gets really hot and melts through the
ice and the other plan they talk about
all the time they want have a big long
tether a big cable so this thing would
melt through 20 kilometers of ice
there's a very
fifteen miles of ice and look around in
the your romanian ocean it would be an
extraordinary thing then this is a cool
thing and we're very excited about it at
the Planetary Society but the drawback
is humans being what they are and
Congress being what it is here in the US
when something that ambitious are that
expensive or that pricey is put in a
bill what often happens is the other
side the Senate you know the US
government has two houses just like
Lords in common and they though the
other side will cancel that that money
set aside but we'll see
either way there is a mission going to
Europa and there is a proposal to make a
very sophisticated complicated lander to
look for signs of life below the surface
the extraordinary and I hope it happens
while you're alive I hope it does stay
tuned